okay so when you were gonna be here
we're gonna talk about your movie which
it just come out but now it's under
right DVD and all that so let's talk
about it now I saw it it's amazing it's
I think it's your best movie ever Wow
yeah because I remember when you when
you called me and you were so excited
about this idea and I can tell you we're
excited because you did it like that I
mean you got the idea and you got your
crew together I mean you were out doing
it within a month get within a month
amazing and what it basically is of
course is it's called we're doin date
decks but it's really what to steal next
you know you go to all these countries
that do things better than we do in
Italy they give people paid vacations in
France the school lunches are great in
the Finland is it that the prisons are
Norway the prisons are awesome and they
have a low recidivism right Portugal the
drugs are legal Iceland has a limit on
the vina upper limit on the number of
women so it has to match the number of
men right Parliament 40% of the Board of
Directors in Raceland a corporation have
to be women and the punchline of the
whole movie not to give it away is that
really these are all American ideas
aren't they we we really just need to
steal from ourselves right every
everything every country we went to they
would tell us the progressive education
that was an American idea made a that
didn't start in Moscow that started in
Chicago when there were riots so over
the eight-hour day all these things that
we started and then we gave up on we
gave up on ourselves we gave up on the
country that a lot of people wanted it
to be and and so the Europeans just want
well you don't want you know good health
care for everyone and right paid
vacations and paid maternity leave and
these things will do it and so they've
done it and they do it they do it in
their prisons
you mentioned Norway and Germany and
these other places where they have
Norway as a 20% recidivism rate because
they treat inmates as human beings and
their whole goal from day one there the
warden says to them on day one you're
going to be my neighbor someday because
we don't have the death penalty and we
don't have life imprisonment so that
means you're getting out of here and you
could be living at my street so I am
committed to helping you do whatever -
so that you're going to be fine when you
get out of prison and and so
80% recidivism rate in this country 24/7
always and I think when people hear
about all these great benefits that they
have in other countries they think well
the taxes are higher but you raise a
great point which is actually our taxes
may be lower nominally but not really
because we have fees on so many things
and we like to ition co-op pays is due
to long right the nursing home for your
parents these things are free or nearly
free in these other countries so while
they pay a little more in taxes we don't
call them taxes here but if you add our
taxes to the tuition to daycare fees
nursing home fees all the co-pays
deductibles we pay a lot more than the
French and the Norwegians and all these
countries and and get less and get less
get farland and this I mean and this is
I mean we're talking in broad parameters
but this is basically what Bernie
Sanders is selling this is really why he
has caught on I keep writing it right
okay yeah it's a new deal you pay a
little more in taxes but you get so much
more and in the end you you are
out-of-pocket less overall for
everything because you don't have
$100,000 of student loans to pay off
you know you don't have to pay for
daycare when you have a job you get you
know I like in Italy there's six to
eight weeks paid vacation that workers
get and and these other I think to be in
the European Union actually your country
has to have four weeks paid vacation as
the law and you have to have paid
maternity leave and you can't have a
death penalty if you have any of these
things you can't be in the European
Union and in Europe do they poison their
citizens with lead
I mean now that your app is perfect
look your picado yes men crowd and yeah
I would rather live here but but I went
there to show people the good things
that are happening cuz all I hear about
are Oh Italy is a mess you know forming
a new government it's 10 million lira to
$1 they never show us the real life that
they have and how happy they are and why
they live four years longer than we do
you